so yesterday we had a
night dive planned with some friends on
the boats
and in between that we had some time to
stall
so i called kristen and i was like hey
let's go get some pictures
um you know we were originally looking
just for some rocks or something with
some pretty
footage in the back previously i was a
photographer and so i knew that if we
could find something
picturesque like that
we would have some great footage so we
kind of went around the lake i didn't
know exactly where that boat was
but like you everyone has seen it all
over facebook and youtube
so we went around a little bit and we
found it it just so happens that the
boat after what we were about to give up
and the boat just happened to turn and
kristen said there it is
so we got as close as we could obviously
we had to you know climb some hills
but we got uh we got there and we set
each other up and luckily got that
footage
um so i've been mermaiding for quite a
while um i was actually started out at
ripley's aquarium in south carolina many
many years ago um i was born and raised
in vegas but my background is marine
science so i moved back out here i'm
actually mainly employed with the
silverton which has their mermaids
and then patty which is a big scuba
organization came out with their mermaid
program and it just fit hand in hand and
now we can have many many people become
mermaids and play around with tales and
it's a lot of fun
what's the deal with mermaids
well for me you know for me it's
imagination um you know we grow up
chasing rainbows and riding unicorns or
at least the idea
of that so for me it kind of takes me
away from the everyday struggle of the
things we see on the news
um all the tourism that's going on here
so it gives me a way to escape what's
going on every day now you know
negatively
when you go underwater whether it's
scuba diving or
being a mermaid um it's a whole other
world
you see things and you you just
experience something completely
different